minneapolis derek shovin's murder trial
resumes this morning
with more police officers expected to
testify for the prosecution
the city's police chief told the jury
yesterday that shovin violated police
standards in training
when he held his knee on george floyd's
neck for more than nine minutes
jamie yukas is outside the courthouse
with more on this story
jamie why are the prosecutors calling
these police officers to the stand
because this is highly unusual to see
police testifying against other
policemen
gail you're absolutely right it's rare
to have officers testify against former
officers on trial
prosecutors are trying to give the
jurors information about police
procedures
and according to the police chief
chauvin should have stopped the neck
restraint
once floyd stopped moving the chief told
jurors chauvin's actions ran against the
department's policies
and ethics to continue
to apply that level
of force to a person
prone out handcuffed behind their back
that that in no way shape or form is
anything that
is by policy is not part of our training
and it is certainly not part of our
ethics or our values
minneapolis police chief madeira
arredondo told jurors monday
former officer derek shovin did not
follow proper policies
while it is absolutely imperative that
our officers go home at the end of their
shift
we want to make sure and ensure that our
community members go home too
and so sanctity of life is absolutely
vital the chief told the court chauvin
failed to provide even basic aid to
george floyd
the defendant violated our policy in
terms of rendering aid
the defense made the point that at the
time of floyd's death both conscious and
unconscious neck restraints were allowed
both
were permitted under minneapolis police
policy
on may 25th 2020. agreed
yes but the chief asked to clarify
it is contrary to our training to
indefinitely place
your knee on a
prone handcuffed individual
for an indefinite period of time
inspector katie blackwell oversaw the
department's training at the time
i don't know what kind of improvised
position that is
so that's not what we train cbs news
legal analyst ricky clement
does derek chovin almost have to take
the stand to defend himself now
there are very few cases where i feel
that a defendant needs to testify
the only person who can say that he
thought that he wasn't
causing enough harm for death or serious
bodily injury because he had done this
maneuver
before is derrick shoven
focusing on use of force is just one
part of the prosecution's case
the other is proving to the jury that
chauvin's knee
on george floyd's neck led to his death
yesterday the emergency room doctor who
tried to revive floyd testified
he died from lack of oxygen that is a
crucial argument in the prosecution's
case
chauvin's defense countered that could
be related to the drugs in floyd system
tony it all comes down to the jury jamie
thank you very much